the heroic path is laid out in like as a
meta path by religious systems basically
as the road to redemption and the
redemption is redemption from chaos but
also from tyranny it's Redemption from
both and in it in the transcendent space
that those meta stories exist
that's a divine archetype right it's the
successful hero but then that's an
archetype means so you know let's say
you're doing everything right and then
your family gets killed in a car
accident and you slip and fall down the
stairs and you know you have a
concussion and maybe you wake up in your
brain damaged you know so and then while
you're recovering you get hit by some
other illness because that often a
one-two punch like that will often
really hurt people you know because
they're they're just getting up they're
quite fragile and they're pretty hurt
and then something else comes along
watch them and you know it isn't the
case that identification with the
archetypal hero will stop those things
from happening because there's an
element of randomness in life so so you
have to be sensible about it you have to
say it's your best bet which is a
different thing it's no certain path but
given the range of potential negative
outcomes voluntary confrontation with
emergent anomaly roughly speaking gives
you the best poker hand or maybe makes
you the best poker player that would be
a better way of thinking about it now so
people can be traumatized by by failure
to update their models because then the
model gets old like Osiris and it's
unable to see the tyranny plus it's
archaic and can just get wiped out
because it no longer is adapted to the
situation it's like you would be like
that if you were still using daus as an
operating system well it's a perfectly
reasonable operating system but it
doesn't it yulian used to really work
but all you had to do was not update and
you'd be extinct right one of the things
Mircea Eliade a pointed out was that one
of the processes that sort of
universally regarded as a sin insofar as
that's a universal conception so you
might think about it as a mana error is
speeding along the process of inevitable
decay through willful blindness so
things will decay of their own accord so
you have to be awake just to keep the
bloody thing alive but you can speed the
rate at which it decays by pretending
that nothing's wrong and and refusing to
change anything at all and so then you
say well not only does it decay but your
blindness is contributing to the decay
and that's well in one of the stories
we're going to talk about today which is
the flood story that's basically the
underlying story of the flood is like
God's pretty irritated that everybody's
blind and stupid but he's particularly
irritated that they stay blind and
stupid and so the consequence of that is
everything gets washed away and that
actually is the consequence of that so
when the ancient Hebrews were imagining
that story you know when modern people
look faced that story they think well
what kind of God would do that it's like
well we talked about New Orleans
why did New Orleans get washed away well
one answer is hurricane that's a good
answer but the other answer is maybe
they should have made the dike stronger
like they knew for the last 100 years
and maybe all the money that was
supposed to be spent on the dikes
shouldn't have got diverted into the
pockets of corrupt politicians and so
then you say well why did New Orleans
get flooded hurricane or the sins of man
and the tendency of things to decay well
the truth is is that they're both
equally potent causal elements you know
when your city collapses because your
engineers have built the concrete with
sand which happens all over the world
right like especially in corrupt
countries where they don't make the
concrete properly because it's cheaper
just to fill it with sand the whole
bloody city falls over it's like is that
the earthquake
well yes because it wouldn't have
happened without the earthquake but it
also wouldn't have happened if people
weren't corrupt so and there's a
constant that's the dynamic between the
terrible mother chaos and the terrible
father like an and the the other dynamic
there is also the adversarial element of
the individual you can't assess the
situation without taking those three
causal forces into into consideration
simultaneously someone just gave me a
paper a couple of weeks ago
linking corruption to poverty now I knew
that for a long time because if you look
at the list of if you look at countries
and rank them by GDP and then look at
their corruption indexes it's like this
is a tremendously high correlation and
you might say well poverty causes
corruption but really that's what you're
gonna say you're gonna say that poor
people are corrupt really no I wouldn't
do that first of all there's lots of
poor people who aren't corrupt but
corrupt people are poor you can bloody
well be sure of that
so Adina dip well yeah absolutely
absolutely I mean the ruble is falling
like mad you know and there's a variety
of causes of that but Russia is corrupt
beyond belief you know so and corruption
corruption is like inertia you know if
you and I have a transaction and we both
stick to what we say I hardly even have
to think about you you know you're just
you're a cent and so on a page what a
good deal but if you're not that god
only knows you might you know you might
wipe me out because I'm trading with you
you know I mean I've had business
dealings with people some people I don't
even have a contract with we just say
what's gonna happen and that happens and
for years you know and then other people
it's like detailed contracts they take
really six months of work to lay out and
they're violated continually and it
turns into just an absolute catastrophe
and so the cost of that is exceptionally
high you can't have a transaction that
can be profit
roughly speaking in the presence of
corruption because the transaction cost
is too high and so it just spirals into
poverty and you spend all your time
trying to figure out what the hell the
other person is up to instead of you
know concentrating on what you could
actually do so I think the only real
natural resource is honesty you know one
you might think well that's you know
what's your evidence for that like
that's not a problem
in stable democratic countries the best
predictor of long-term success is
intelligence and conscientiousness it's
like isn't that an index of isn't that
in the index of the integrity of the
system I mean I don't see how you can
argue that any other way conscientious
people are diligent dutiful and honest
they do what they say they're going to
do and smart people are faster so
basically what the data reveal is that
if you're fast well you're gonna get
there faster than other people because
you're fast and then if you're fast and
honest the probability that you're gonna
move up your doorman is hierarchy is
it's massively massively increased you
know the over RR is probably about 0.6
relationship between IQ and
conscientiousness but a lot of that's
measurement error you know because I
can't figure out how conscious you are
with a conscientious you are with a
questionnaire there's gonna be a lot of
measurement error there there's less
measurement error with IQ but then the
performance indexes are also full of
measurement error right because it isn't
easy for me to tell how well you're
doing I could use estimates your income
self reports of how you're doing peer
ratings of how you're doing your
supervisors ratings of how you're doing
your subordinates ratings of how you're
doing how much money you make if you're
a salesman or someone who has a direct
income but that only captures you know
what a small maybe that captures 60% of
your success or something and if that's
the case then the are for the
measurement of your success is only
about 0.75 and so if they're if the if
the measurement error for for IQ and
conscientiousness tops out at about 0.7
which is probable and the performance
index our accuracy tops out at about 0.7
a correlation of 0.5 is like it's not
35% of the variance
it's like 70% of the measurable variance
so you know and I can't think of a
counter explanation for that now if you
look in creative domains you have to use
openness because and you have to use
different measures because creative
people it's not it's not easy to assess
the performance of creative people if it
was they wouldn't be creative because
the problem with creative people is they
keep mucking with the structure that you
would use to assess them you know so you
couldn't assess Picasso as an
impressionist that just isn't gonna work
so it's very hard for people to think
about what to do with someone like
Picasso because he demands that you come
up with a whole new rating scheme and
that's you know that's the real problem
with creative people so but anyways I'm
gonna talk about this summit this
mindmatters thing on Sunday because I've
been thinking about power you know and
we were well we can segue into this so
we already talked about how the great
mother emerges from chaos and so this
idea that's God the Father by the way I
think that's a Eastern Orthodox
representation and the Eastern Orthodox
Church split off from Western Christian
Church in was a long time ago I don't
remember exactly when it was within two
hundred years of the 10th century so I
know that's a fairly big error and I
can't remember exactly the difference
but it was way before the Protestants
and the Catholics split for example so
it happened a long time ago but the idea
here is that there's a structure that
emerges out of chaos and that structure
is symbolized by the Father and
basically what the father represents is
the the model of behavior and perception
that has been constructed by history so
roughly speaking it's what the feminists
referred to as the patriarchy except the
problem with the feminists is they only
see the tyrannical element of the
patriarchy and you know a lot of the
reason for that is because they were
strongly influenced by the postmodern
philosophers of the late 1960s who were
almost all without exception radical
left-wing student revolutionaries who
were working for the overthrow of the
government in the late 1960s so it's
like there's a problem with that the
problem with assuming that the Great
Father is only tyrannical is well first
of all it's ungrateful because that you
know you're in the university and I know
that as a general rule University of
Toronto students aren't you know the
happiest creatures in the world and
their reaction generally to the
University and I think it's because the
workload is pretty damn high and the
place isn't that social you know um
they're stressed and unhappy especially
in their first couple of years but what
are you going to say about that you're
gonna say the whole bloody institution
is nothing but a tyrannical mess it's
like if so what the hell are you doing
here you know you've got to give the
devil as do so maybe it's 30% oppressive
and ridiculous and 70 percent good I
mean what would you say what do you guys
think how would you balance it you've
been through the university you've in
your 4th year what proportions would you
suggest 30 70 okay well one of the
things I can tell you that that's a hell
of a lot better than most institutions
right so you know even if it's not the
ideal which perhaps it isn't compared to
actual institutions rather than
comparing it to a utopian ideal it's
like not too bad you know it didn't
crush you completely you know and well
you guys are all gonna graduate and
that's actually getting to be of some
benefit and there's even a possibility
that you know more than you did four
years ago right you haven't starved to
death and all those things and
everything you taught wasn't a complete
or was we're taught wasn't a complete
lie you know so all things considered or
ate it's 30 percent
you know man-eating tyrant and 70
percent benevolent father and maybe we
could push that up to 80 20 or something
or maybe 85 15 but believe me you're
never gonna get it past that I think at
some point your attempts to make it
better than that will actually make it
worse you know so there's in there it's
like in the in the old Egyptian story of
Seth and Osiris
and Horace Horace comes along and chases
seth away but he's just you know
hovering around there out in the border
you don't get rid of them so you're
never gonna get completely rid of the
tyrannical element of your cultural
heritage and that's partly because it's
made out of the past and the past is
dead and blind for obvious reasons you
know all the people who made it are dead
so it's it's static dead and blind but
that doesn't mean it isn't worth knowing
about and you know your job
fundamentally is to revivify it one of
the things I often do in this class I'm
not doing it this year is show students
Pinocchio because you know Pinocchio is
a dramatic tale about a marionette whose
strings are being pulled by forces he
doesn't understand transforming himself
into an autonomous individual and a
variety of things happen - Pinocchio he
has to deal with corruption in the form
of the criminal underworld and the devil
himself sort of lurks behind that in the
story he has to deal with the the
temptation of e to pull neuroticism
because at one point that criminals
entice him into being useless and lazy
because he's too sick to stand up for
himself and then he also has to go deep
into the sub into the into the oceanic
depths to confront chaos itself and when
he does that he finds his father who's
blind and dying roughly speaking and
brings him up to the surface and now he
actually sacrifices himself to save them
you know even though the story insists
that you know while the father's
drowning after the whales been chasing
around he basically says you know I've
had it Geppetto I've had it swim to
shore and save yourself
Pinocchio refuses and drags him to shore
and then he dies at his reborn and then
poof you know he's real it's like yeah
exactly right and so you know part of
your obligation as a student is to come
to the University that's 15 percent
corpse or 30 percent corpse will say and
make the bloody thing come back to life
without assuming that it's all
tyrannical and just rejecting it you
know and it's very dangerous to do that
because first of all if the past is
corrupted - Ron
so are you because you're an embodiment
of the past insofar as your enculturated
you know so it's not like it's outside
of you it's inside of you too so that's
that's a hell of a thing you're gonna
write off your are you going to write
off your socialization completely as
nothing but tyranny I mean that's a big
problem a it's not true although for
some of you it's probably more true than
others and be well if that's the case
and you're utterly utterly corrupt what
the hell do you think you're gonna do
about it
so that's a big problem you know plus
it's ungrateful and that's a big mistake
because you know if you're ungrateful
you can get arrogant and then you're
really in trouble and you are trouble
sure well that's that's exactly why I
made reference to what happened in the
60s you know because the idea then part
of that was because people thought them
a Vietnam War was staggeringly unjust
and part of that was because people were
pretty tortured existentially by the
underground battle between communism and
and and and the west roughly speaking
which was you know breaking out all over
the world including in Vietnam so there
was a lot of in underground turmoil but
part but that doesn't mean you get to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
you know when Timothy Leary was a good
example of that turn on so that's the
LSD tune in drop out it's like no no no
turn on wake up and adopt some
responsibility you know and so what you
see cuz as soon as you go to drop out
you think well are you running away or
leading and Nietzsche would say you're
running away that's what you're doing
the probability that you're leading is
vanishingly small the probability that
you're deluding yourself about being a
leader when you drop out is exceedingly
high so the right assumption is if you
drop out you're useless and lazy as well
as arrogant and resent
and you should start with that
presumption and then go through you know
cataclysmic soul-searching to see if
maybe it might not be true it's true you
know what's the probability you know
saint or loser
well that's there's so few Saints that
you just using baseline predictions
you know actuarial tables you have to
assume loser so you know and if you're a
loser who thinks they're a saint
well then you're gonna cause an awful
lot of trouble you know so and that a
lot of that happened in the 60s so you
know the 60s generation likes to think
about themselves as admirable rebels
it's like yeah let's let's check a bit
for some self-serving tendencies there
you know like the refusal to adopt
responsibility and that's always lurking
underneath like a revolutionary facade
so you know and I think that's had an
absolutely pernicious influence on the
universities especially the humanities
which are dropping in enrollment
cataclysmically deteriorating in
influence and based far more on you know
the the what would you call it the the
idea that you have a moral imperative to
be a radical activist it's like no you
have a moral imperative to be useful and
honest that's the whole that's a whole
different thing you know if you want to
change things like fair enough
but don't be thinking that change isn't
dangerous and that you're right it's
highly unlikely so so anyways it's very
my point is there's an archetypal way of
representing the great father and the
archetypal way is tyrant or or
benevolent dictator it's something like
that and you don't get to just say one
of them now you know here's a way of
thinking about it historically you could
say that once like these are archetypal
and religious representations so you
could say we're roughly that's God the
Father
the farther you see there is ruling over
a walled city and the wall acidity is
the farther as well because it's an
enclosed space that's keeping chaos out
and there's a hierarchy in there a
dominance hierarchy and everybody
slaughtered in the hierarchy and you
could think of the the dominance
hierarchy and the value hierarchy as the
thing that's manifests itself as the
father symbolically speaking so and that
you're protected by the fact of the
hierarchy even though it also oppresses
the hell out of you maybe you're like a
serf you know but maybe maybe it's
better to be a serf than to be someone
alone in the middle of a battlefield
you know the that's certainly possible
you can make a case for that anyways so
then you look at that you think well is
that tyranny or security and the answer
as well it's both and what's the ballots
and what you hope is well let's have a
little more security than tyranny and
then what's your moral duty well to
ensure that the Great Father who you are
not bloody well going to get rid of and
you better not because you'll end up
like the Mesopotamians when they slew
absolutely you remember what happened to
them right absolute was T amounts
Consort he was the masculine element
chaos in ordered as soon as the ancient
gods were formed they made a lot of
racket and they were really careless and
they killed abso and then they lived on
his corpse well that's not a very good
idea because then time out comes you
know swarming back and the probability
that she's going to do you in with all
her monsters unless you really pay
attention and speak properly is very
very high
you know the Mesopotamians have that
figured out well are they it and they
may have it figured out in image it's an
absolutely remarkable a remarkable story
so yes
[Music]
okay there's two questions in there one
of the ones was sometimes it would
provide a lot of both well I think
that's what happens when you're
subjected to extraordinarily high
standards you know is that order or
chaos well it's both you know because
there's massive benefits in high
standards the problem is is they provoke
anxiety and they're very hard to attain
does that make them bad there's no
saying it makes them bad end good and
it's even more complex than that because
whether they're bad or good depends on
how you react to their they're in
position
if you discipline yourself and
straighten yourself up and learn a
tremendous amount and achieve the high
standards that's way better for you than
if this high standards weren't there but
they're also gonna crush people you know
they're gonna crush people for all sorts
of reasons they're gonna be really hard
on people who just aren't that fast even
if they work really hard or they're
gonna be really hard on people who are
quite fast but really don't work very
hard they're gonna be hard on people who
you know have impediments to their
progress in one unfair way or another so
the tyrannical element is exactly there
so you know I think the whole bloody
thing degenerates into tyranny when the
people inside it are doing nothing but
lying that's the pathway to tyranny you
know on and and I would also say that
that's the hallmark of the adversarial
personality you know we've talked about
the Great Mother creation and
destruction and the Great Father
tyranny and security but on top of that
is the individual and there's the part
of the individual that's heroic and I
would say that's exploratory attentive
and capable and willing to articulate
the truth insofar as that can be
conceptualized and then his polar
opposite which is the opposite of that
willfully blowing and deceitful at every
possible opportunity
unity you know and there's certainly an
interaction between all three of those
levels you know and I think that's part
of the reason you know one of the things
that happened in Christianity was that
the serpent that was in the garden God
associated with Satan that's very weird
thing you know it's very unlikely when
that story first emerged that the
serpent had any association with the
idea of the adversary at all but as the
story developed through time what
happened was if you construe the serpent
as chaos itself and maybe the negative
element of chaos it was easy to
associate that with the tyrannical
father so there'd be a satanic allel
iment to that and the adversary himself
right because it's all negative so
that's the that's the connection between
the three levels and it took Western
culture roughly speaking thousands of
years to delineate that idea you know it
probably didn't come to its full poletik
flowering until milton and it's very
little of it is in the the bible as it's
as it as it currently stands virtually
nothing that's one translation Lucifer
is also the bringer of light though
weirdly enough so you know it's a it's a
very it's it's it's well it's again it's
one of these paradoxical situations
because it's also not always the case
that your adversary is the devil so to
speak it might be an angel in disguise
you know and that's use notion with
regards to the shadow you might think
that it's evil but it might be the thing
you actually need now lurking underneath
that is the idea that there is absolute
good and absolute evil and I think you
can make a case for that in fact I think
the 20th century made a case for that
and I think that's what was decided at
the Nuremberg trials after World War two
because the judicial decision was there
are some things you don't get to do no
matter what your culture is like and no
matter what your Excuse is you know and
the alternative that to that was
deciding well we can let you off the
hook because you were following orders
you know when people really debated that
and you can say well the Nuremberg
judges were the Allied victors and so
they just impose
their own viewpoint but I think that's
pretty damn cynical it was probably some
of that because things are tyrannical
and benevolent at the same time but you
know accepting that judgment is a very
peculiar metaphysical move but rejecting
it that's also a very peculiar
metaphysical move
you know because basically what you say
if you if you reject the nuremberg
decision is that what happened in the
Nazi concentration camps was had to be
judged through the lens of cultural
relativism so you can say that if you
want but you know it's not one of those
things that you should do lightly
because well you run into Dostoyevsky's
problem Dostoyevsky's problem
fundamentally is if there's no order you
no hierarchical order if there's no God
then everything is permitted and you can
walk down that road but it doesn't lead
to a very good place okay so so you know
what we're trying to sort out is the
idea we're trying to propose the idea
that what what myths are doing is trying
to represent the the fundamental
elements of being as being is
experienced at every level of being so
it's not a reduction to chemical or
physical constituent elements it's a
it's a perception of the world as it
manifests itself at every level of
existence simultaneously and it's
predicated on the proposition that
there's no reason to make any one of
those levels primary from an ontological
perspective so what that would mean in
part is that the web of relationships
that you find yourself in is just as
real as the physiological components of
your cells now obviously in some sense
it can't be measured or even
conceptualized in the same way but that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that the
relationship isn't real you know so it's
it's a much more comprehensive way of
looking at things and it tends to take
on this dramatic and imagistic form I
think because well first of all it was
acted out before it was under
stood its second images can capture all
sorts of things that words cannot yet
Express which is why we like we like
looking at profound artistic images
they're filling us with information you
know what I found out recently that
Heidegger whose ideas actually have a
fair number of similarities with what
I've been teaching you
except I'll tell you something
interesting that I think is true so
Heidegger tended to view modern
civilization he tended to view it as the
tyrannical element of the Great Father
stopping us from being able to interact
with pure being so he was very
his proposition was that we reconnect
ourselves with the pause development of
being and producer produce a culture a
social culture that was much more
benevolent but I think if you think
about this from a Union perspective what
what the union's claim and this is F
Alfred Adler claimed the same thing and
so did meet you to some degree is if you
tilt too far in one direction a counter
position develops in your imagination
and starts to have an uncanny influence
on you so I can give you an example so
I've had clients for example who are way
too agreeable you know so maybe they're
pushed around by their father for
decades and you know one of the ways
they react to the hyperaggression of
their father or the dominance of the
father or maybe their own weakness is
that they classify dominance and
aggression as evil and then refuse to
engage in it of course that just weakens
them further but then they harbor
resentment you know and so one of the
things you suggest is that it if you get
gripped by an emotion you need to let it
manifest itself in a fantasy you know
and I've had my clients tell me
fantasies once they've learned to let
the manifest themselves you know they'll
be irritated for example by something
their father says and they'll let the
fantasy play out and it's like not only
is it murderous like you would not
believe but it's viciously and violently
murderous you know and what happens
there is that because the little issues
that constitute the tyrannical element
of the relationship between them are
never dealt with the part of them that
is capable of standing up and and and
pushing forward has been assaulted by a
million blows and it's soul it's been
pushed into such a pathologically
defensive position by that point that it
doesn't fantasize about well maybe I
should have a chat
with my dad and settle this it's like oh
no no no it's like full-fledged
murderous impulse and by that time the
person is also terrified even to let
that fantasy emerge because then they'll
think oh my god you know am i some kind
of serial killer or some kind of
homicidal maniac and you know the answer
is well of course you're partly Alma
sidle maniac you know you got to keep
that stuff under control so otherwise
you take it out on your children and the
people that love you and all of that but
that's not so bad if it's you know
manifest in day-to-day trivialities and
you kind of keep things sorted out but
if you don't do anything about it for 20
years you always hear about these guys
that burst forth and do something ultra
violent what are the neighbors always
say especially if they're the lone
killer types well he was such a nice boy
you know we never saw him he never
caused any trouble it's like yeah right
he never caused enough trouble that was
the problem but he sure made up for it
in one fell swoop
so anyways back to Heidegger Heidegger
had this Heidegger seemed to have this
vision of the patriarchy roughly
speaking as hyper dominant and then
valued the opposite which was more
cooperative and more in tune with nature
and you know sort of like an
environmentalists dream of what human
society should be like and I say that
seriously because I believe a lot of
what the modern environmental movement
uses to drive its its utopian visions is
actually derived directly from
Heidegger's thinking I mean you can
trace that the causal pathways you got
to think remember what happened to
Heidegger though he became a Nazi you
know when it was a real shock to
everyone who is a Haida gariand follower
because it always seemed like such a
good guy it's like yeah well maybe he
was too good a guy you know and so there
was the he was all sweetness and light
so to speak on the sort of patriarchal
end of the distribution and then the
counterbalance to that manifested itself
politically and he was just pulled right
in so I think one of the differences
between what I'm proposing and what
Heidegger proposed is that like I would
never say that that
there's a utopian solution to the
problem of the Great Father I would say
you're stuck with the positive and the
negative you're stuck with it now I
think through diligent effort you can
keep the positive on top of the negative
but you don't do that by sacrificing
strength you know you don't get rid of
tyranny by weakening society all you do
then is you increase the probability
that when tyranny bursts forth it's
going to be far more brutal than it
would otherwise be
you know you increase the benevolent
element of of society by increasing its
competence and power so you make it more
powerful not less now that doesn't mean
more that doesn't mean more oppressive
right they don't so that's that's a
Solzhenitsyn problem so one of the
things Solzhenitsyn wrote about was he
was in prison in the prison camps in
Russia for a long time and one of the
things that he used to amuse himself
with in the darkest possible way with
his compatriots was teasing communists
once they got arrested you know and it
was pretty brutal because once you were
thrown into the gulag system the
probability that you were going to get
out especially if you were a political
prisoner was like you're in there for
twenty years you know and you're lucky
if you didn't get worked to death and
the thugs and the murderers and the
thieves didn't beat you senseless
constantly till there was nothing left
of you so it was no joke to be thrown in
the gulag if you were a political
prisoner and there were lots of people
who were thrown in there purely
arbitrarily and that's actually because
if you really want to punish someone you
punished them because they didn't commit
any crime that's a way better punishment
than punishing them if they actually
committed a crime you know cuz that's
just justice but random punishment if
you want to be brutal that's the one to
use
so the Communists would get thrown in
with the prisoners who'd been in there
for a while and they'd still be like
rampant communists they'd be writing
letters to everyone and trying to
extricate themselves from the situation
assuming that a mistake had been made
you know and Solzhenitsyn his
compatriots would just tease the hell
out of them because they had nothing
less left to lose
plus they thought well you're still part
of the goddamn system that actually
imprisoned and brutalized yourself and
us so part of Solzhenitsyn's moral
problem was what should i do with you
like should I feel sorry for you because
you've fallen into this absolutely
hellish category of that person betrayed
by their own ideals and their own person
or should I treat you like well
serves you right because you're blind
tyrant and look at what you've produced
and souls in it since answer was you're
a blind tyrant till you repent right so
as long as you still think you're right
there's no possibility of communication
so then what he observed was some people
would collapse they'd admit and maybe it
took a long time that maybe there was
something wrong with the system and that
the other people in there weren't all
the guilty ones and them the only
innocent ones so some people would
accept the facts even at whatever brutal
cost that would be and what that would
be was starting to decompose the entire
value system they had that was
predicated on axiomatic communist belief
but the other ones and these are the
ones that sozin instance also writes
about they just never changed
you know released 20 years later they'd
say well that just proves the system was
right all along and that I was in error
because you you know you can always
interpret the data the data does not
speak for itself that's a big problem so
so I thought his solution was brilliant
it's like well what do you do with
someone who's still acting out what has
destroyed them well until they
stop being part of that you can't really
forgive them or communicate with them
but as soon as they drop it it's like
well then you give them a hand which
seems to me like a reasonable balance
between justice and forgiveness and
that's a very hard balance to strike
right it's a very hard balance to strike
so okay so then I kind of differentiated
this into the tyrant is the king that
eats his own son roughly speaking and
that means that like if you have a
tyrannical father say in your actual
family what that father is going to do
is to react to everything that makes you
independent or that could make you an
independent being as if it's a challenge
to his own authority and dominance and
so whenever you stand up you know and
make your little thrust forward like you
would if you were a three-year-old you
know you're gonna get whacked hard for
it you're gonna get punished for
everything that would allow you to climb
a dominance hurricane to become a
challenger and so that's that's sort of
the paternal element of the eatable
situation you know mother who demands
nothing and farther who punishes
everything good it's a perfect
combination if you want to raise someone
who's completely demolished and also in
in high probability resentful and
dangerous so and you know you have
societies like that too you know you see
this in corporations especially when
they start to deteriorate as they start
to punish the people inside the
corporation for being hardworking and
creative and you know the thing is in
real trouble at that point it's
basically dead it might take 10 years to
fall over but it's basically dead so and
you know as corporations as hierarchical
structures get full of people who are
doing nothing but trying to climb the
dominance hierarchy you know their power
motivated they're very annoyed at anyone
who's competent and creative because the
competent and creative people are using
competence and creativity to climb the
hierarchy whereas they're just using
political machination xin the desire for
power so they want nothing they don't
want to have those people around because
they are his competitors and they're not
even that they don't even actually care
if well they're climbing the the ladder
on the ship that the thing is sinking
you know in fact they might be
facilitating its sinking and trying to
pirate everything they possibly can well
the thing falls apart that happens all
the time so when it happens in all sorts
of institutions so that's sort of the
Sun eating farther representation in a
political or corporate institution you
know when it's sort of what's
interesting about that I think is that
both the Liberals and the Conservatives
see that they say the left wingers and
the right wingers the left wingers see
the tyrannical element of the Great
Father in corporations and the
right-wingers see the tyrannical element
of the Great Father in the government so
it's projection you know I mean it seems
to me like a radical oversimplification
to assume that all the evil is embodied
in the government or all the evil is
embodied in corporations it's like you
know we should be a little more
differentiated than that
so all corporations are not the same
obviously and all governments are
clearly not the same and all
governmental policies are clearly not
the same but people are lazy so they
don't want to do the differentiation and
so what happens is that the archetypal
representations possess them initially
and they failed to differentiate them
you know when they're pretty happy about
that because their Theory explains
everything you know I asked I talked to
a guy a while back and he's a pretty
smart guy and I was thinking about this
issue of corruption I was trying to
think I thought how the hell did some
countries get not corrupt because I
cannot figure that out I cannot
understand how that can even be possible
and for me that's a massive mystery like
I can imagine
digging through that for like 30 years
trying to sort it out and he answered in
two seconds he said well it's government
I thought you know all that means is I
don't I don't want to think about that
and so here's my one-word low-resolution
answer that covers fifty thousand snakes
at once it's not helpful you know it all
it does is
convince him that he possesses knowledge
because he's using low representation
representations to encompass huge swaths
of the complex world you know what's so
yeah yeah well but what that is exactly
so so the reference there is you know
people people have tried to model
optimal social interactions you know so
should we cooperate or should we fight
and so first of all the people who tried
to model that we're doing it in one offs
so you can make a case that if I if if
there's $20 at stake and I could get $20
by like giving you zero I should do that
if I'm only going to interact with you
once and so the initial experiments
basically showed that if you were a
psychopath
you'd win but then someone figured out
that well wait a minute
you don't ever do anything once you
iterate it and that's a pH aryan idea
right because Piaget would say well
what's the stable solution across
multiple iterations of the same thing so
it's like well what if we always
cooperate a group of us we always
cooperate well there's a problem with
that because then psychopaths will pop
up randomly and he's like a shark in a
tank of Gabi's he just eats all the
Guppies and that's the end of this
situation so if all we do is cooperate
someone who's non cooperative can eat
immediately get everything we have and
so then the problem becomes well you
don't want to take full of sharks and
you don't want to tank full of Guppies
what should you do an answer because
this has been played out on computer
simulations by the way all over the
world is well how do you ensure
stability and it's something like I
trust you I start with the presumption
that you're trustworthy if you react in
a trustworthy manner away we go we trade
and it's transparent
if you screw me I whack you and then I
offer to trade with you again
cool and that seems to be now that's
really worth thinking about because
there's a shadow idea in there right
it's like I trust you but if you bother
me I'll bite you and I'll bite you hard
but then we can trade again so it
doesn't that what that allows is that
you can screw up you know and you will
so it means that we can continue to play
even if you're not perfect but you're
going to get punished an appropriate
amount if you're not perfect and then
we'll try to get the game going again
and so I would say that's an example of
a pia jetty and equilibrated solution
roughly speaking and it could ease it
could be that that does have something
to do with the way that a culture learns
to become non corrupt but it still
doesn't explain how that gets
implemented you know so okay so the
there's a walled city you know and
that's that's a that place exists that's
in France and fortunately I can't
remember the name of it at the moment
it's one of the best-preserved medieval
cities in the world and there's actually
quite a few of those left in Europe I've
seen a lot of them and they're
staggeringly beautiful unbelievably
beautiful so but you see how those
things were constructed a because
there's a double wall right and so you
think about what's the psychological
message that's embodied in that city and
the messages inside the walls where
there's a civilized organization you're
safe from barbarians and chaos and the
barbarians and chaos surround that and
so it's better to be inside the city now
obviously the problem is the city's
walls so it's not that easy to get out
you're trapped in there you know in some
way so that you could see while you
could find you imagine if you're a
teenager in a medieval city like that
you're 12 years old or 13 years old
you're off with your ratty little
buddies and the first thing you want to
do is go outside the wall and see what's
out there but by the same token if there
weren't any walls well then the
barbarians would come in and they'd
steal everything you had and everyone
would be dead and that would not be a
good thing so you know it was also a
place to store prod use argue cultural
produce so that it couldn't wouldn't rot
and wouldn't get eaten by bugs and
wouldn't be stolen by thieves you know
so and that was also its
ordinarily useful and so there's a
belief system embedded in that that's
that would be the medieval world order
but as well as there being a belief
system and a psychological
representation it's obviously a physical
structure and it's also a mode of
relationship and all of that together
constitutes the Great Father it's not
just the belief and some of that's going
to be tyrannical because there's a king
and some of it's gonna be beneficial
because well maybe better to have one
king than thirty kings they're having a
war so that's been the dilemma in
American foreign policy you know if you
give American foreign policy some credit
you know which you which is a reasonable
thing to do because part of the what are
the Americans were always trying to
figure out especially since the end of
the world war world war was is it better
to have a tyrant or to take them out and
have thirty of them you know an answer
to that is who knows you know so they
took the tyrant out of Iraq what
happened
you know the country basically fractured
and it happens very frequently it's it's
a quasi failed state you get little
fiefdom zuv warlords basically who are
certainly no improvement over the
original tyrant and they tear the place
apart now I'm not making a case for the
utility of a tyrant but but the opposite
of order is chaos and chaos can be just
as destructive as tyranny or maybe it
can be more destructive so you know the
same thing happened to some degree with
the Arab Spring it was like okay poof
chaos it's like everybody thinks well
this is a chance for a new beginning and
you know it seems like in places like
Tunisia that actually worked and the
things loosened up a bit in Morocco too
so there's some indication of some
progress but in places like Libya it's
like well that looks like it's
degenerating into complete hell and you
see the same thing in many places in the
Middle East where the Arab Spring
occurred so
the that's also why it's so necessary to
understand what lurks behind tyranny
because what lurks behind tyranny is not
freedom it's chaos and Harris has the
potential for freedom but then it
depends on what people do with the chaos
so and it's not it's not self-evident
that the chaos is better than the
tyranny and part of the reason for that
is that in every society there are
agents of chaos and they're people
they're often out you know relatively
low strata on the dominant circuit
they're usually young men they're
usually extremely aggressive they are
usually incredibly resentful and
displaced and for them as soon as chaos
appears it's like it's open season you
know the the struck the society has been
restructured and they can just go about
taking everything they want so you know
you see that even in countries like
Canada where those are the guys who riot
after a hockey game you know they need
no excuse whatsoever to go out and chaos
and act like absolute barbarians hmm
absolutely yeah but they it's a it's a
it's a causal interrelationship you know
there's a whole chapter on that near in
the last third of maps of meaning
describes the relationship between the
two halves of the adversary there's a
nihilistic element and a fascistic
element you know and once the value
hierarchy falls apart one response is
let's go in there and get up the gold
and rebuild something you know I'd say
that would be the heroic element but the
adversarial element is well everything's
falling apart it's every man for himself
and the fascistic element would be me
right I'm gonna exert power not for
competence dominance pure dominance and
that's like rape and pillage that's what
that is so you know and that's what it
is and you know if you contrast that
with utter powerlessness
you can see how rape and pillage might
be attractive and you know that's also
why I think it's attractive often to
young men at the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy who are dispossessed you know
elated one of the things we know is that
if you have a fairly flat dominance
hierarchy so that opportunity is
distributed and there's a reasonable
probability of getting from the bottom
to the top so you have hope let's say
then the males at the bottom don't get
very aggressive but if you get the damn
thing pointed up so that there's almost
no possibility of moving forward even if
you use competence then the males at the
bottom especially the ones that are
disagreeable so they would be more
warrior types man they get aggressive
right away and they're they're gangs
they dominate the gangs and they go to
war with each other
and the reason for that is that the
successful gang members are far more
successful as successful gang members
than they would be successful as low-end
poorly paid conformists now most of the
guys in the gang are worse off actually
so some of the best anthropological
evidence that's being collected suggests
that most people in a drug ring so there
are the people at the bottom make less
than they would if they were working for
minimum wage but it's a lottery you know
partly the violence helps because that
the top of the dam hierarchies being
peeled off by deaths all the time so
there's always the possibility that
you're gonna pop yourself up three or
four levels and then you'll have a
riotous old time for the next five years
till you die which would be a lot better
than having a chaotic existence with
nothing for the next five years until
you die so you know part of part of what
societies always have to do is to make
sure the damn dominance hierarchy
doesn't get so steep and unclimbed that
all the ordinary men at the bottom start
to get hyper violent it's well
documented and the best work on that was
done at McMaster and I can never
remember the people who did the work
unfortunately can never remember their
name it'll come to me so yep
strategy then right right but you know
people generally don't do that
calculation you know remember when the
Americans went into Iraq what did they
think what was the theory will be
welcomed as liberators
well that was actually true in some
cases for about a week but the problem
was they wiped out the power structure
they dismantled the army and you can see
why
but then what the hell are all those
soldiers gonna do they're soldiers they
know where the weapons are they're not
just gonna sit around especially not the
hyper aggressive guys who are already
soldiers they're gonna think to hell
with this you know it's chaos and I'm
gonna get what I want it was so
interesting when I saw that happening
because they wind and wiped out Saddam
and then there was all these people
stealing computers and things from the
government offices and the Western media
kept saying looting looting and I
thought it's not looting you just wiped
out the legal system there's no legal
system anymore it's not looting cuz that
would be against the law there is no law
you just wiped it out he was a dictator
now you could say well those people
should have followed the law as if it
was there
it's like well you wouldn't have gone
into that country if it was true cuz
that would only be true if the law was
just because if it wasn't just then why
the hell should people obey it and if
you'd been terrorized by people for 30
years and you could take a computer it's
like who's to say that isn't exactly
what you should do you know the West
acted like well actually natural law
governs this and Hussein is just a what
do you call an anomaly and so you take
him out and then there's natural law and
you should follow it as I wasn't looting
there's no looting when there's no law
well that that's it that that's exactly
that's exactly right so well they almost
they also might blow it apart at such a
high level in the hierarchy that there's
no bloody way you're going to be able to
bite off and digest the huge pieces of
taya math that happened to be laying
around you know so one of the one of the
because part of the reason I was trying
to lay this out over these years is
because I was trying to figure out since
there's a relationship between the
adversarial element of the individual so
that would be the part that's willfully
blind and it likes to lie and tyranny
and the abolition of the positive
element of chaos you know and the
tendency for deep for things to
deteriorate those are all causally
linked in a really tight manner that's
Solzhenitsyn's observation and Frankel's
observation and Havel's observation it's
the whole essence of existentialist
thought okay what the hell are you
supposed to do about that and the answer
seems to be don't have it happen and so
you say well when should you stand up
against tyranny well you should stand up
against tyranny when it manifests itself
at micro levels right in front of you
that's what you have to do and so that
means you have to be awake all the time
for transgressions against the positive
element of the individual and the pause
development of culture and you have to
do it right then in there and you can't
say and people say this all the time
well I can't take my boss on at work
it's like well what's gonna happen to
you well I won't get the next phrase or
maybe they won't like me it's like well
that's fine so that's that's that's your
courage what are you gonna do when
there's a real tyrant well we already
know the answer to that if you're not
even gonna stand up when you're
protected beyond belief by the structure
and you have everything you possibly
need and you could probably even stand
up without with and get away with it or
you could even stand up and you would be
more respected and the
probability that your career would go
properly would increase you're not gonna
do it then well you're certainly not
going to do it when it's Saddam Hussein
or Adolf Hitler like forget it man it's
way too late for that now the problem
with that is that there's not a lot of
self-evident heroism in it so you know
you don't get to go party in the streets
about how brave you are but but one of
Solzhenitsyn claims in Frankel as well
was that it was the accumulation of
micro lies that built up to produce the
Nazis and Estela mists
so it was bottom-up and top-down at the
same time lots of causal
interconnections and loops but basically
people put up with the first imposition
that was only this big and then they put
up with the second imposition then they
put up with the third imposition and by
the time they noticed that it was really
like a major league imposition pointing
it out would get you arrested
well then man then the stakes like there
and when does it end well it doesn't it
doesn't end it just gets worse and worse
and worse and worse and worse you know
and it almost starts so bad in 1962 and
in 1984 it almost got so bad that we had
the third world war like it was that
close so what where it ends is
apocalypse and so that's why you see
very often in religious writings that
the sins of the individual are linked to
the apocalypse the reason for that is
they're linked to the apocalypse that's
why it's just that you don't see the
causal connections so okay any questions
about that okay so there's the
representations in a bit more visible
form so you know this is you're trying
to get the thing on the left to be
working properly and you're trying to
stop the thing on the right from taking
over completely and it's it's a real
balance because you don't know for
example even with your own children how
the hell do you know when you're
terrorizing them and how do you know
when you're socializing them one of the
things that I noticed with my kids and
this was much to my chagrin was lots of
times I was
confining them in a tyrannical manner
because they were having too much fun
you know cuz you always think you're
punishing your kids so to speak when
they're doing something bad it's like no
you're not you're yelling at them
because they're running about like you
know completely insane impulsive manic
hyenas and they're having a great time
and so you say calm down you know what
do you treat what are you gonna turn
them into some kid that can sit there in
their desk for eight hours when they're
in grade two and not complain it's like
is that an improvement well yes and no
so I also noticed with my kids that when
I was more tyrannical than might be
popular now especially with my son I'd
crack down on them now and then because
he has been a little rodent and he was
really he was really pushy he's a
doorman and kid you know and I don't
know if you've ever had a doorman at
door but you have to flip those things
over you know on their back all the time
because otherwise they just push and
push and push he was sort of like that
and so he'd get all uppity and then I
talked to my wife and we'd say all right
so we're not gonna let him get away with
he can't even breathe wrong for the next
two weeks you know so every time he did
a micro mistake we were on him and I you
know like this is a bit much but what
was so bloody weird about that was every
time I did that he liked me better it
was so interesting you know but I think
it's very much like the situation with
the DOM and the dog it's like partly
what the dog wants to know is who the
hell's in charge and if it's you he's
perfectly happy about that but he
doesn't want there to be any ambivalence
about it so oh well like if he if he if
he did anything that I thought was a
little crooked or a little deviant or a
little too pushy what I would usually do
with him is make him sit on the steps
you know I'd say okay here's the deal he
could communicate more or less at this
point because he was around two and a
half to three the deal was you sit there
until you've got yourself controlled and
you're willing to be a civilized human
being and then you can come back to me
and tell me that and if I like you then
I'll let you come up so because you know
sometimes you'll have a kid do that
they'll come back and they
they say what they think you want to
hear but they don't mean it and so you
think oh I'll give them a chance but
that you can't do that you have to see
if you like the kid now because if they
come up properly and say things so that
it's it's like true all the way down
instantly if you have any sense you're
not angry at them anymore you think yeah
I like that kid and then so so so you
know if your goal is to produce a kid
that you really like which i think is a
really good goal then you don't let him
off the damn hook until he's that kid
and it was really interesting to watch
what that did to him and I think it was
part of cortical integration and
cortical integration of hypothalamic
impulses he'd sit on the damn steps like
this you know just enraged and I'd go
over to him and I'd say well you know
are you ready to get off the steps yet
and he'd go not yet you know and then
he'd get himself together and then he'd
come and talk to me and then I'm like my
rule was as as soon as he did it right
it was over no grudges nothing it was
done you know and so that was also very
rewarding for him because he could
specify the length of punishment the
length of punishment was as long as it
took him to start acting like a
civilized human being again and the
consequence of that was end of problem
so that's you know that seems to that's
like tit for tat fundamentally bug me
whack but as soon as you're straight
again poof we'll we'll trade again so
and you know what I noticed about him in
particular can he was the dominant kid
was you know you'd set a rule whatever
the rule was like you had to be maybe
you had to go to bed at 8:00 or
something it was like well what happens
if I wait till 8:15 you know or 8:05 or
810 like he he just push until he knew
exactly where the line was very pushy
but it was also extraordinarily
exploratory right because someone says
there's a rule but you don't know what
that means
so what do you do you've harass and push
and push and harass until you find out
where the boundary actually is and if
it's nice and firm and doesn't move
around then you think oh that's like a
table and if I stand up underneath it
I'm going to whack my head so I won't do
that and then you move on to something
else
but if the dam boundaries are going like
this all the time the kid will just
torture you forever
so which is exactly what he should do so
I think whether or not you are going to
tyrannize your child in the final
analysis depends on exactly what acting
ethically in general depends on which is
in the final analysis do you want to
make things better or worse what he
aimed at and you know you there isn't a
way of there isn't really a way of
managing that unless you get the whole
hierarchy clear in your head you know do
you want to make the world a better
place well part of that is do you think
it should exist at all
are you resentful because it's tragic
and and limited are you angry because
you're not as successful as you could be
do you have 85 unresolved things with
your wife you know are you intimidated
by your child if he happens to be
successful maybe he's gonna be more
successful than you you know you think
you're gonna be able to tolerate that
you know those are all questions you
have to think through and you need
answers to them you know and if your
goal is I'm trying to produce a child
who's better than me first of all then
you have to admit that there could
possibly be something that would be
better than you you know and then you
have to think that it's actually your
responsibility to facilitate that and
you have to be committed to it and
without that well to the degree that you
haven't got that formulated and
articulated and embedded in you and
acting it out in your household you're
going to be a tyrant especially when
you're tired and upset and hungry and
you know maybe you failed at something
and you've had an argument with your
wife or so I don't think there's any
general rules except you know have a
relationship with a kid and keep your
damn eyes open and make sure that you're
aiming at what's best for that child and
you have to love the child to do that
and then you have to figure out which
part of the child you actually love so
you know in therapy I always envisioned
myself Rogers it was unconditional
positive regard that isn't the way I
look at it it's like if you come for me
to therapy I'm on the side of you that
wants things to be good
I am not on the side of you that does
not want things to be good you know and
we have to sort that out and I'm
assuming that the reason that you're
coming for therapy is because you would
rather that things were going to be good
and so I don't even think it's
appropriate to be on the side of the
client that is aiming at death and
misery you know the fact that it's there
means doesn't mean you should throw the
person back out on the street you know
because it's there so in that sense the
regard in some sense is unconditional it
isn't unconditional it's that's not the
right way of thinking about it you make
a contract which is okay our purpose is
to narrow the influence of evil and
expand the influence of good and we're
going to tell the truth to each other in
an attempt to figure out how we do that
and we're not going to blow the
relationship apart if horrible things
come up as long as we're both convinced
that that's what we're aiming for and
the communication is actually honest and
so it's unconditional in that you won't
break it if things happen that are
pretty unseemly but it's conditional in
that no no I'm on the side of you that's
going to tell the truth and that's going
to aim towards the good and that's
actually what you want from me you know
it's sort of impartial what time is it
okay let's let's stop for 10 minutes